police in albuquerque new mexico are
increasing security at mosques and
schools after the recent murders of four
muslim men there authorities believe the
killings may be linked and they're
asking for the public's health local
investigators and the fbi say they are
looking for this
vehicle of interest that's what they're
saying omar villafranca has made his way
to albuquerque for us where he's talking
to members of the muslim community there
omar good morning
good morning we learned this is a small
muslim community around three to five
thousand people and they are scared the
mosque president told us that some
people have even moved away until a
suspect is caught and cbs news has
learned after talking to federal sources
that the fbi is looking to see if these
are hate crimes the work of a serial
killer or both
they shot him
and the cigarette was over there right
there
emotions are still raw for sharif heady
more than nine months after his younger
brother mohammed zaheer ahmed was killed
behind their family's halal market in
what investigators say may be a targeted
attack
you put your heart into this business
yes his heart not my heart was his heart
i have to run his heart right now
the brothers were born in afghanistan
but fled during war in the 1980s now
hedy tells us he like others in the
muslim community feel terrified
do you find yourself looking over your
shoulder be honest with you i don't care
about my life anymore
when i lost
my lovely brother
authorities announced they are
investigating a possible link between
his brother's murder and the murders of
three other muslim men
the most recent victim 25 year old naim
hussein was shot just hours after
attending a funeral service for muhammad
afsal hussein and aftab hussein both
were also killed in the last two weeks
local police brought in the fbi after
the second murder
over the weekend investigators and the
fbi released a photo of what appears to
be a dark silver volkswagen jetta which
they say could be involved in all four
murders
ahmad asid is president of the islamic
center of new mexico
what is the reaction of this community
it's a one astonishment one of one of
disheart they're disheartened they're
concerned they're living fear
people are so scared they're missing
prayer service well they are i mean
they're missing their daily routine
they're missing their life they're
missing their sanity
muslim leaders are telling the faithful
that they can pray at home if they don't
feel safe police have set up an
anonymous tip line and the reward is up
to 20 thousand dollars nate
omar thank you